بعد سرقه القرن التي هزت الراي العامه في
العراق كشفت دائره التحقيقات بهيئه
النزاهه العراقيه مؤخرا عن اختفاء اكثر من
82 مليون دولار من ايرادات احدى الشركات
التابعه لوزاره الصناعه والمعادن في
محافظه بابل
المبلغ المفقود اختفى في الفتره الممتده
من سبتمبر ايلول 2017 وحتى سبتمبر ايلول
2022 لكن هيئه النزاهه امتنعت عن ذكر اسم
الشركه وعدد المتورطين في هذه القضيه
القضاء العراقي ماض قدما بالتحقيق فيها من
اجل التوصل النتائج وبعد التوصل النتائج
وبعد اكمال التحقيقات سواء كان من مجلس
القضاء الاعلى سواء كان من القضاء العراقي
سواء كان من الهيئات التحقيقيه المنبثقه
عن هيئه النزاهه او الفريق الساند عند
غايه يتم الاعلان وكشف النقاب عن ماهيه
المتورطين وعن اعدادهم وعن اسم الشركات
وعن حجم الاموال التي تم اختلاسها وسرقتها
اغلب المستندات التي تحتوي الارقام
والاحصائيات الخاصه بالحسابات الختاميه
لخمسه اعوام تم اخفائها من قبل الموظفين
المسؤولين عن المشروع ما دفع هيئه النزاهه
الى اعتقالهم للتحقيق معهم في واحده من
اكبر قضايا الفساد التي هزه البلاد مؤخرا
ربما هذا الملف يعني حسب المعلومه انه قد
يكون من زمن لعبادي ثم الى عادل عبد
المهدي ثم الى الكاظم يعني قد يكون بين
2017 الى 2022 او 2021 فلذلك هذا الملف
لحد الان في طور جمع المعلومات لكن
الموضوع ليس غريبا عما يجري بصوره عامه في
العراق عملا باحكام الماده نهايه العام
الماضيه اعلنت هيئه النزاهه العراقيه عن
تشكيل هيئه عليا للتحقيق بقضايا الفساد
الكبرى في البلاد والتي تصل الى 11 الف
قضيه ثبت فيها تورط
605 مسؤولين بينهم 54 وزيرا من بغداد
منتظر رشيد العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد
من الاخ قليل الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك
في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر
الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات